[Music]
attention all catholics in the room
that one right
a discovery you grew up catholic i grew
up catholic had a catholic priest in
arizona who performed thousands of
voters yeah this is kind of funny what
happened what happened uh he said one
word incorrectly and now thousands of
baptisms do not count so he was the one
so they're all going to hell
[Laughter]
you're in the church too i like how i
like how the church is throwing this guy
under the bus for one word era
and they're like hey all the all the
priests who are uh you know molesting
little boys yeah they're all good thank
you come on let's just let's just those
kids are definitely touched by christ
made an honest mistake
you think he can just make a confession
and then god forgives the sins it's not
supposed to work you think god is like
no this dude [ __ ] up he is going to
burn in hell got it god is actually
grammar
i think cadabra's are good
i i don't know anything about the
catholic religion how do you think he
messed up skippy doo
skippity dude he's this guy's bigger
than scatting huh
when do i remember getting baptized well
do you remember what they say like
during this year
we were just good just freezing that was
just the modern way of saying jesus
sorry my bad i was trying to slang i
guess
during the baptism you say like oh i
baptized you in the name of the father
of the son and of the holy spirit yeah
he had been saying the he baptized you
oh
yeah
it's a group effort so you can't say
that's what i would argue i mean
grammatically he's talking about three
entities that's a jaded priest the whole
thing is that it's specifically heavily
not a group effort oh it's only god
you're like as the bab as the baptizer
you're representing the lord and
because the holy spirit is a different
entity it is not the community that
baptizes a person rather it's supposed
to be christ in him alone is it supposed
to be he baptizes you i i think i i
think that the i think the spirit is
there the holy spirit
and you should just are we really that
[ __ ] literal
i think the catholics are then all the
all the priests who [ __ ] little boys
i agree thank you what does the [ __ ]
bible say about priests who [ __ ] boys
what is it should they be murdered guys
they already rotated we're fine now
the rotation's helped they help to help
you they're just trying to cover up
their [ __ ] this stuff like this
pisses me off
i'm sorry like
thank you tasha come on man
in a religion like this have you guys
been a catholic seriously for those who
are i have yeah so you know how like
it's very ritualistic with all the like
sayings and the things you have to
recite that's why my mom left
my mom is a pro she went to catholic
school we'll show up to like catholic
weddings i grew up hindu or a funeral
and like my mom will flex when we're at
the [ __ ] church doing what yeah
anything don't be like it so today we're
gonna be doing the him or like the
opening prayer and you know like when we
do like hindu chants like she's like
you're very you know
oh but not in church when it's like
english she'll be like
[Music]
and i like and i'm like what the [ __ ]
what is it that sounds like like i don't
know it's like in sanskrit i don't i
don't understand it so it would be the
equivalent of them like doing prayers in
latin why is she doing it like so crazy
because she wants people to know that
the indian woman in the church is about
that knows
more about the hymns than they do yeah
she's about that life because she went
to catholic school that's a weird flex
bit it's a weird flash
that's a good definition but i can see
like my dad didn't go to catholic school
so he has no idea so he's not even
trying and like obviously none of us
know what's going on my mom's like that
too where she does she goes to like a
buddhist service yeah and a lot of us is
in sanskrit too and yeah so when she's
seeing it they'll just like um the
enunciation they'll write with chinese
characters but they're trying to
reproduce sanskrit sounds oh [ __ ] dude i
want to see i want to hear this but
my mom being like a karaoke champion
do the best impression of it because i
know what
like a hindu priest sounds like so i
want to know what
like a buddhist there's a chant that i
knew
written in sanskrit in chinese
yeah
like she thinks she's still in a [ __ ]
kitchen
yeah yeah so she'd be like people it's a
very like zen you know everyone's just
cheating calm and relaxed calming and
she's the only one
saying it in jodeci she's she's using
her diaphragm yeah yeah yeah imagine an
r b singer that converts to buddhism
dude that's gonna be so sick he's gonna
hold his ear and [ __ ]
yeah that'd be fine dude your mom and my
mom should start like a duo oh of
religious chanting
not in the same religion though doing
different other other cultures oh it's
like it's like a dueling song yeah dude
they're gonna keep going back and forth
they're like dueling pianos except it's
just dueling hymns dueling moms so yeah
so he's freaking out obviously
um isn't it all about forgiveness man i
don't get it
this doesn't make any sense you can't
nitpick this you can't nip the ghost he
just needs to make a confession what
they're saying is that the all of those
are void like that didn't even go
through because he [ __ ] up one word so
now they can't go to heaven
might as well be buddhist
or be hindu man
can they re-baptize them free right now
i guess they even have to get a refund i
don't know if something like this is
really happening come on can't the pope
just say it's all good yeah absolve him
he did with the the molesters right
everyone who got raped yeah i mean yeah
i absolve you didn't happen he probably
was like all the people who raped you
they're good
so he he resigned by the way like he's
watched no longer he's one of the
actually i don't know
growing up
but the rapist just got relocated that's
[ __ ]
this is such an interesting what's wrong
with the world dude this is i know this
is insane it's [ __ ] mind-blowing this
is the because it's so stupid
it's so stupid
anything they say i'm just like okay but
are you raping kids yeah that's my
question
are you okay that's fine set the bar
real low yeah like you you hurting kids
what's up
that's all we have to i don't get it
it's so ridiculous bro what are we doing
here did he get paid out was the church
is like hey we'll just give you a
million dollars for you looks like fred
armstrong
their garments are [ __ ] crazy it
looks like a fake baby no that's not a
real baby dude have you guys seen those
videos
is that supposed to be is that supposed
to represent christ
babies he's allowed to baptize from now
on yeah that's what i would say why is
he holding a fake baby
catholicism the baptism happens as a
baby yeah have you seen those baptized
when you're older and stupid it ain't
like us where you gotta prove you
deserve it yeah yeah cause our or when
you're protestant or whatever you have
to wait till a little bit older and then
you have to go through like the baptism
is when they they dip you in the water
and then you're like refreshing and it's
it's you're accepting christ
no that's kind of do an opposite smooth
criminal
have you seen those videos of the babies
where they take the babies
and they're hella rough i like how they
do i like when they do it multiple times
because
[ __ ] yeah dude apparently babies well i
don't know
can it happen at any moment or is it
like a year two years is there's a
specific age i feel like it's pretty
early um they want to get you in as soon
as possible because babies are very used
to bodies of water being in the blue you
were baptized as a baby yeah i think so
is it what was that like is there a
video is there are we getting dunked no
i think it was a dunk tank
like what if he's doing the moonwalk
as a as a baby like a kick
he's
like oh but i said the word wrong it
doesn't happen it doesn't count
leave them in there but you dumped me
the church that i went to didn't dunk
because i went to a baptism once i think
they yeah they just kind of like lightly
dip they don't like booze
it's not like it's not like uh the roast
beef juice
do you want like single dip ashoo double
dip full dip no they're not you don't
get to choose it's definitely like a
half dip it was like a gentle half dip
oh man see i like the gentle half dude i
like dunk churches man yeah me too yeah
did they let you just like cannonball
into the holy water
it's up to you
oh man i'm still really upset
is is the priest emotionally affected by
this that's what i really probably
probably feels like you [ __ ] up his
job or emotionally
how come he didn't sell out any other
priests like what what about that guy
that [ __ ] touched his kids
exactly
you gotta get you you guys are amazing
how how is it that not a single person
right people you would assume and just
every single nun the people who are
trained in catholicism
were like hey it's actually i
like after 20 years not one person was
like yo yo dude hey just just so you
know it's just eyes and it wasn't just
like oh okay thanks
like who was like i'm reporting you to
the catholic church this is the this is
the bad boy cop this is or this is the
bad boy priest it was just like no we
say we already yeah he's the cool guy
bro he's doing play priest
he's the fonzie prince
what if he's like yo dreamwork makes a
team work it's wee baby he puts on his
sunglasses like lights a joint well this
is what this is the thing in in here is
canon father i don't know if it's
i don't know if this is a hindu concept
or more of just kind of like an indian
concept we are always taught growing up
it's
parents
teachers god
in that order in that order it's not god
your parents are above god all parents
and teachers parents teachers
wow
that's pretty funny so parents are above
god yeah in the sense because
because parents give you everything a
parent definitely wrote this
yeah we're gonna rearrange the [ __ ]
there's a famous there's a famous story
you know in in in hinduism about ganesh
the the elephant god
and his brother who he rides a peacock
okay
his brother rides peacock just just
those stories are [ __ ] amazing just
go with me the elephant is writing the
peacock all right
ganesha's parents
uh are shiva and parvati okay shiva is
the the the guy with the spear right
many arms the angry woman
oh many are okay that's you're thinking
of kali who's a female oh okay she's the
goddess of death nice so shiva is he he
represents destruction he's ganesha's
father he's usually portrayed blue yeah
oh who cares a spear got like a fire and
[ __ ] yeah so he has a third eye when he
opens up its destruction like it
instantaneously obliterates you lit sick
so anyways i forget how the conversation
goes they're like hey we're gonna have a
foot race we're gonna have a race
between the brothers
uh you have to travel around the world
three times first person to travel
around the world wins three times boom
the brother on the peacock goes great
i'm gonna win this takes off bang ganesh
goes okay
brother goes around the globe comes back
i did it i won and ganesha's like nah no
you didn't you didn't win he's like what
do you mean i went around earth three
times he's like yeah but i went around
my world three times and he walks around
his parents three times oh
that's fire and he's like no i won the
race and that's why you should love your
parents love your parents my mom also
hug your parents everybody my mom also
told me there's a saying that there's no
such thing as a wrong mother
written by a mother
i think every mother would agree with
your mom
this game feels rigged i don't like this
guy though
i was like man it's [ __ ] convenient
of your ass
that time i left you in a boat i was
right
tell that to moses's mom
you